the first video back for 2021 and we're
doing a double giveaway
that's right two amaze fit watches are
going to anyone
anywhere around the world so stay tuned
during this video to find out how
you can win one of these two products
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is david
thomich and welcome back to the channel
on this channel we usually talk about
technology and architecture and
everything in between last year just
before christmas a bloke called jason
sent me an email from amazefit and said
hey
we've got a couple new products do you
want to test them out so i thought to
myself
you know what hundreds and hundreds of
these emails hit my inbox
every other day and none of them
actually come to fruition
most of the companies just pretend like
they're going to send you something and
never do
so i decided to do my generic response
as i always do
and you wouldn't actually believe it but
within three days
both of these products arrived at my
doorstep so i couldn't help it but i
actually just had to review these two
products
out of just genuine respect for the
company and their ability to actually
follow through with their actions so
today we're looking at
the amaze fit gts and the amaze fit
gtr we're going to begin with the
unboxing and then go through with my
full opinion
of both of these products and exactly
how you can win one
if you want to just jump ahead to the
giveaway portion make sure you jump
through
to that time stamp i hope you're paying
attention
and you'll be able to learn how you can
win one of these two products
okay so today we have two products from
a maze fit that have been sent through
to us
the gts and the gtr model they're both
fitness trackers and i think today we're
going to start by unboxing the gts
it's very very similar to the
apple watch the box itself very basic
nothing special on it same with the gtr
just a picture on the front some very
basic information
the rear is covered with stickers all
over the shop both of these boxes
arrive from amazon prime so i'm sure the
stickers and the boxes will look a
little bit differently
around the world all right so let's
start by cutting open
the gts and taking a look what comes
inside
if you're using a knife make sure you be
careful obviously guys
very simple very basic very very very
difficult to get this
watch out of the box but once you get it
out you don't really need
that overarching box anymore it comes in
a very
simple slide out case pretty premium
quality
cardboard here again a little bit of
resistance
but overall not too bad
nothing over the top nothing inside this
cover
so again you can get rid of that that's
no longer required
hit the camera my bad okay so move
beautifully is the slogan for this gts
watch it comes with a sticker on the
face and a pull
tab so want to take the pull tab out
again
more wasted cardboard more rubbish
unfortunate to see
but i don't think there is anything you
can do about it in this case
opening up the box three compartments
you can see
a little instruction book on the left
hand side
a maze fit branded what appears to be
the charging cable
um let's open this up and see what we
have
very standard usb a type
cable rubber little
holder usb a table and
what appears to be about a meter long
charging cable with a docking station
branded amaze fit i'm hoping you guys
can see that there
overall relatively basic no charging
brick in the box
so going with an apple style no charging
brick
bit frustrating but i guess we all have
plenty of charging bricks laying around
a little simple plastic over the top
comes off very smooth
very satisfying i always tap it on top
of the instruction book don't ask me why
just something i do
silicon band for the actual watch strap
feels relatively premium overall i'm
very glad they sent me the black model
as i'm hoping you guys will be
as this is a giveaway plastic on the
rear for the heart rate monitor
plastic on the sides nothing special
nothing overly high quality
however pretty decent feel pretty decent
fit
a little bit too tight if i'm being
honest and a little bit hard to put on
but overall i think it was maybe 190
brand new if you're looking to buy one
of these watches not bad for a first
impression
unboxing it okay so let's move on
to the gtr which is more of your i guess
garmin galaxy style smartwatch so we'll
push all the gts side
stuff aside and we'll begin opening the
gtr
the gtr i'm hoping is a little bit
better quality
than the gts but having said that the
gts isn't bad quality whatsoever
that one coming up came out a lot
smoother than the last one
again sorry hit the camera same
amaze fit branding quite nice very
simple very
elegant again lots of wasted cardboard
quite a nice looking device i don't like
that high polished
chrome stainless steel whatever it is it
looks very
cheap we haven't touched it yet so i
don't know if it feels cheap but it
looks
very very cheap uh same style packaging
cable on the side book on the other
nothing special i'm guessing they're
exactly the same
identical yep little book we're not
going to look through that that's not
that important
cable let's open this up see if it's
exactly the same as the last one yep
so we have that rubber band again
silicon style
flicked off a little bit too far there
and again about a meter long cable
usb a and a very simple docking station
that looks to be identical and
interchangeable so it does leave a
little bit of fingerprint marks there
yeah exactly exactly the same
a little bit magnetic too so i don't
know if that has
any use or relevance to you guys but
they are magnetic on the rear
obviously they charge with a magnetic
connection
and yeah unfortunately this does feel a
little bit cheap
once you take off the plastic that's the
main face again
on that book overall we have
a nice looking device a little bit
cheap feeling again very silicon
strap with a i guess pleather fake
leather top
amaze fit branding on the strap there
a plastic back overall
90 plastic and silicon strap
the strap feels a little bit tacky in my
opinion but
it's a fitness tracker it's not meant to
absorb sweat you're meant to be able to
swim with it so i guess silicon is
probably
a good choice the branding i don't mind
it's quite clean quite minimal
how it sits it says pretty well i'm
being honest it's not too
it's a little bit tight again they both
seem to be a little bit tight or a
little bit too loose
overall pretty comfortable good size
overall full disclosure i have
relatively small wrists so these watches
probably look a little bit
bigger than they will on most people but
they do
feel pretty decent for again about that
200 australian dollar mark if you were
to pay for these
not the worst first impression and they
probably feel a little bit more premium
than anything else okay so the unboxing
is now finished you know exactly what
you're entering to win
if you still want to win one of these
products either the gtr
or the gts it is very very simple guys
one make sure you're subscribed to this
channel smash that subscribe button down
below that's all it takes
to jump on my instagram the link is in
the description box below
and follow me on instagram and three
finally make sure that you leave a
comment down below
commenting one what model you want
either the gtr or the gts
and to your instagram handle so that way
i know when it comes time to selecting a
winner
how to actually find and contact you
guys it's a mistake i made in my last
giveaway
but it is something that i've rectified
in this one the t's and cs are very
simple there will be
one overall winner for each device one
gtr winner one gts winner
across all social media platforms so
if you've entered on youtube if you
vented on instagram if you've entered on
twitter whatever you've entered on it
all counts as
one entry the only one that's really
going to count and the only one
that i'm going to be looking at is
youtube so make sure
that you've commented down below the
winner will be announced at the end of
january
2021 on my instagram page i will tag you
guys directly
so make sure you send me a dm after you
see that
if there's any other questions you need
to know about this giveaway let me know
down below and i'll get back to you as
soon as possible
now let's talk about the actual physical
product itself
i wore both of these devices for a
couple of days each tested them out
throughout the day
took them to the gym and tried to
actually understand what it would be
like
owning one of these now i'm not a big
smart smartwatch fan myself
so i don't own one in my day-to-day life
it was a very different experience for
me to use
a fitness tracker especially but it was
something i started to enjoy by the end
of the experience
having said that there is definitely
definitely
some cons about these products but also
some pros
so let's start going through them one by
one the physical elements of both these
watches we touched on in the unboxing
but what i didn't really touch on is the
day-to-day use
and feel of them so for example the gts
which is a very similar
apple watch fitbit kind of looking
product
is well very comfortable but at the same
time very
uncomfortable the whole position just
makes it that
little bit too tight or a little bit too
loose
and the silicone strap is just a little
bit too sweaty and too itchy after a
while
same goes with the gtr it is
the same silicon strap with a leather
i'd say pleather top material
but at the same time when you use it
it's always a little bit too loose or a
little bit too tight
so the whole positioning of the straps
isn't perfect now i have the ability and
the experience to comment on this
because i actually used to run
a very large internationally globally
recognized watch company
so i know a lot about watches and i know
a lot about straps and that's why i can
make that comment
very confidently as a smartwatch per se
the software is
very limited so both of them run
identical software it's the amazefit
software
it is a simple fitness tracker and it
pretty much only does fitness tracking
now
why do i say that well it becomes very
evident when you start using the watch
for example the gtr has a lot more
information on it because it's a larger
screen
and it has that ability to be able to
show more detail because of that feature
however the actual ui system hasn't been
integrated
perfectly so for example i went out did
a workout finished my workout and at the
bottom of the screen
half the text was cut off so that's
that is just a very unfortunate
situation to have
it is something that you don't want to
experience in a finished finalized
product there's a whole bunch of other
buggy features on the watch as well
so for example the gts watch here in my
hands right now
i was wearing it on the stationary bike
doing some hit cardio
and tracking my heart rate it was
continuously saying my heart rate was
only at 90 beats a minute
whilst the actual system was saying at
about 130 which
is more in line with all the other data
i have for my fitness activity
so the fitness tracker and the heart
rate sensor in the gts
is not as fine-tuned nonetheless it does
integrate very well with the app which
is also a little bit buggy
crashes all the time and isn't exactly
perfect
has a few spelling errors here and there
but it's something you can get over
it's not a big deal it isn't a very
professional look but
hey at the end of the day the program
works it is a relatively affordable
smart watch at the end of the day
and it does exactly what you needed to
do it integrates with the app very
quickly and
very simply it's very much so just
scanning
the qr code to get it set up and it does
the rest for you
another con about the gtr is the simple
fact that the vibration motors are very
weak and very flimsy
every time they go off it seems like
they're just rattling around
and they're very cheap you can feel and
you can hear the cheap
nature of those vibration motors however
with
the gts which is more than likely
an identical vibration motor but because
it's a smaller package it's probably
more condensed inside it does produce a
much
better vibration that you can feel this
one kind of
hovers in the air above your wrist and
vibrates slowly
whereas the gts you can feel that
vibration in your wrist
so if you're getting those notifications
you're definitely going to be feeling it
a lot more
in the gts then you're going to feel it
in the gtr overall build quality and
durability after a couple days of use
both of them have held up pretty well i
mean i didn't test them to their fullest
abilities this isn't a long-term review
so i can't tell you if they're going to
fray if they're going to damage
or if the buttons are going to fall off
however from
simple understandings of materials the
fact that they're silicon they're going
to last a little while
they will start to crack eventually if
you're taking it to the pool and into
chlorine i'd recommend
washing it and rinsing it off with clean
water after
immediately just to get that chlorine
off same goes with the ocean and salt
from a product point of view as well
they seem pretty durable
they do seem very cheap still like i
mentioned in the unboxing
the gta r is definitely a cheaper
looking product
from a distance it doesn't look too bad
i'd probably go with the brushed
aluminium finish on the sides next time
rather than the high gloss polished
that just gives it that cheap tacky look
the gts on the other hand is a much
better build quality
i think they knew that the apple style
pebble would go a lot better and it
would sell a lot better
so they've actually put a little bit
more time and effort into it it is still
a little bit cheap a little bit scratchy
plasticky
and the silicon on the sports band isn't
exactly the best
but it is a sports band at the end of
the day so you don't want it to absorb
the sweat
and that's kind of the whole point of a
fitness tracker if you did want to
replace the bands you could easily grab
one off ebay i'm assuming for
i don't know 10 20 bucks at the max and
upgrade to a leather quality or
something different if you didn't like
the look of this device
however in general the actual fitness
tracker itself
is pretty decent and pretty well built i
don't have anything too much default
about it
for the price point it comes in i guess
finally the verdict on
the products should you buy an amaze fit
gtr or gts for about 200 australian
dollars
or should you look at their competitors
like the apple smartwatch
the fitbit or even the samsung galaxy
smartwatch
all of these are significantly more
expensive and i guess the only real
competitor to these two products
is the fitbit which comes in at about
400 australian dollars brand new
or about 220 dollars for the previous
model so if you think about it you can
grab a fitbit
previous model for about the same price
as these amazefit devices
honestly speaking a hundred percent
genuine because again
this video isn't sponsored or paid for
the company has just sent me a couple
devices to review
and provide my genuine opinion i think
you'd be better off
going out and purchasing a fitbit
because it is a much more
refined finished product it has the
premium
luxury feel to it it has all the
software bugs
worked out whilst the amaze fit watchers
unfortunately
still have a few issues here and there
however having said that
they are still relatively good devices
for the amount of money they are
if you're looking at buying the top of
the range fitbit of 400 dollars
or the amaze fit gts for i think it's
189
you'd probably be better off going with
the amaze fit especially if you're
looking for
a 100 fitness based tracker
if you're not looking for a smart watch
that can do 101 things
and everything at the same time then the
amaze fit is probably
the right fit for you between the two
models the gts and the gtr i
would honestly recommend the gts over
the gtr
the gtr just has that chunky clunky
cheap feel to it and it isn't as refined
whilst the gts kind of looks like that
apple watch so if you're looking to
jump into that market or like that look
it's probably a better
product but at the same time it is much
more refined it doesn't feel as cheap
the motors work a lot better the screen
is a little bit laggy but
it still does just as good as job as the
gtr
you don't get all the information that
you get on the gtr
it's kind of more limited and kind of
hidden so you need pretty decent
eyesight actually to see most of it
but hey that's the same with all smart
watches so at the end of the day i think
i would recommend the gts
over the gtr anyway that's all for me
today guys thank you so much for
watching make sure you enter the
giveaway
make sure you pay attention to those
steps if you don't follow every single
step
you will not be entered into the
giveaway which means you can't win
one of these two fantastic devices i
hope you got some good information out
of this video today if there's anything
you'd like to know further make sure you
leave a comment down below
i'll try to answer it as best as
possible again if you're interested in
architecture or technology make sure you
smash that subscribe button
and as always i will see you next monday